oh one thing that we've thought a lot
about is how do you scale a high-touch
company without sacrificing customer
success how do you automate those touch
points and
we really subscribe to the notion that
we heard from airbnb's founders which we
do everything manually until it becomes
too painful to do it manually and only
then do we automate
and the reason for this is it really
allows time for learning so you can
learn so much about the process before
you have to automate it and for us this
has been i'll give an example of our
customer feedback process
in the beginning we were doing this very
manually where we had somebody from
customer success reaching out after
every single appointment and getting
that feedback and that was a lot of work
but
those early conversations really helped
us understand the feedback that our
customers wanted to give us and a lot of
times it had nothing to do with the
questions that we were asking so we were
able to take all of those learnings and
put it into a much more effect customer
feedback process automated process that
we use today and the great thing about
being at this stage of a company is that
we have a lot of data that we're now
able to take and start finding
similarities and finding patterns with
so i talked a little bit about our ideal
customer profiles before and that's
important because similar customers are
going to have similar problems and that
we can provide similar solutions for
and for us 99
of our legal customers are going to be
raising the same types of tickets so
we've been able to start creating
processes around those specific types of
jobs that make it much more easy to
scale and to automate another point that
i want to make is when you're
identifying frequent issues that come up
especially when issues that come up when
you're dealing with customers it's
important to be able to read between the
lines so for us it's not just about
asking what is it that the customer is
asking for it's understanding what the
customer actually needs and i'll use an
example from
our invoicing at one point we had 30
different customers asking for 30
different lines on their invoice and
this was taking a tremendous amount of
time as you can imagine
and so what we did is we went and we
took all of those requests and we put it
on a piece of paper and we started just
categorizing and trying to understand
what they were actually asking for and
in the end what we realized is basically
what they needed was a way to be able to
bill their membership hours to different
departments or different locations or
sometimes their own clients and when we
figured that out we were able to create
a solution specifically for that issue
and that eliminated about 80 percent of
the other requests that were coming in
and my final point here is
just getting everybody on the customer
success train and kristen talked about
this in her presentation i'll just touch
on it a little bit here but again
we've had the same experience and i
think there's always going to be
friction between sales and operations or
customer success sales is always going
to want to go bigger operations is
always going to want to run a tighter
ship and what we've done is we've really
just embraced this friction and realized
that iron sharpens iron all the
departments can really help one another
learn more about customer success and
one thing that we've started doing is
we've actually had started having
somebody from operations sit in on the
sales process so second or third sales
call they'll
so a technical person will actually sit
in and this allows the customer to ask
more technical questions but at the same
time it allows us to start setting those
expectations that maybe the sales team
might not understand or be able to set
themselves and vice versa we have our
sales team actually sit in on operations
meeting to understand what some of the
pain points are that they're facing and
the idea is really for everybody just to
understand the role that they play and
as kristin said that we're all on the
same team and understand what those
bigger picture goals are that
that every every department has and so
it's our job as leaders to really help
our employees understand how they're
touching the customers and how they're
giving input and really getting them
excited about the customer success role
and then finally in summary
the number one key to success is really
focusing on the pain point that you're
solving finding that super power and
scaling around it and automating very
late in the process and only when
necessary and making sure everybody
understands their role in customer
success
if you're a business owner you might be
making running your business harder than
it needs to be don't let old software
slow you down anymore it's time to
upgrade to
netsuite no matter what industry you're
in whether it's healthcare manufacturing
advertising hospitality maybe you got a
sas company or dozens more netsuite can
streamline your workflow and improve
your productivity and that's what it's
all about efficiency stop paying for
multiple systems that don't give you the
information you need when you need it
take all that software that's decades
old ditch those old spreadsheets throw
them right in the garbage now is the
time to upgrade to netsuite by oracle
the world's number one cloud business
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control over your financials your hr
your inventory e-commerce and more it's
everything you need all in one place
instantaneously whether you're doing 1
million or 100 million in revenue save
time and money with netsuite join over
24 000 companies using netsuite right
now let netsuite show you how they'll
benefit your business with a free
product tour at netsuite.com twist go
ahead take the tour and then see how all
the scaling big
important companies are using netsuite
never too early to get in there and
understand how netsuite can change your
business schedule your free product tour
right now netsuite
n-e-t-s-u-i-t-e you know how to spell it
netsuite.com
twist to get that free vip tour
netsuite.com twist
you